[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Christian Sievers in allen
einen guten Abend wir zählen auf sie das
hat der starke Mann in China heute
gleich mehrfach gehört von seinen
Besuchern der Präsidentin der
EU-Kommission und dem Präsidenten
Frankreichs wir zählen auf sie dass sie
Russland zu einem Ende des Krieges gegen
die Ukraine drängen wir zählen auf sie
dass sie selbst keine Waffen an
Präsident Putin liefern das war ein fast
schon verzweifelter Appell anping von 2
Europäern in Peking die in ihrer
Europäischen Union bislang keine
wirklich gemeinsame China Politik
hinbekommen haben deutlich näher an der
Wahrheit wäre deshalb so ein Satz
gewesen wir hoffen dass wir auf Sie
zählen können
liegt der Schlüssel für die Zukunft der
Ukraine jetzt also in Peking Miriam
Steiner ist unsere Korrespondentin dort
wir kommen gerade hier vom Eiffelturm
und gleich wollen wir noch Notre Dame
sehen
Peking ist so stark dass sie sowas bauen
können dass es echt nicht einfach
um von Peking mal kurz nach Paris zu
kommen braucht man nicht einmal die
Stadt zu verlassen der weltpark hat
alles ein bisschen in die Jahre gekommen
passend zum Verhältnis zwischen Europa
und China
um von Paris nach Peking zu kommen
braucht der französische Präsident
bereits in Stunden eine
Regierungsmaschine und hat 50
Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmer an Bord
und das hat sich gelohnt wie die
wirtschaftsdeals unterzeichnet werden
das ist sogar ein eigener Programmpunkt
auf der Tagesordnung die Geschäfte
laufen
dabei hatte
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
vergangene Woche das Ziel ausgegeben
unabhängiger von China zu werden das
wiederholt sie und liefert die
Begründung gleich mit warum die Deals
heute doch irgendwie schon in Ordnung
sein
wir müssen Risiken minimieren das
bedeutet uns auf die problematischen
Bereiche zu fokussieren während wir
anerkennen dass es eine Mehrheit an
Gütern Dienstleistungen und Geschäften
gibt die unproblematisch sind
für China zahlt sich aus auf diese neue
Strategie nur leise reagiert zu haben es
braucht Europa seinen größten
Handelspartner für seine angeschlagene
Wirtschaft doch die Europäer sind auch
mit einer Forderung im Koffer nach
Peking gereist
ich weiß dass ich auf sie zählen kann um
Russland zur Vernunft und alle
Beteiligten an den Verhandlungstisch zu
bringen
sie sagt zumindest teilweise das was die
Europäer gerne hören wollen
was die ukraine-krise betrifft so
besteht China darauf den Frieden durch
Gespräche und eine politische Lösung zu
fördern China ist bereit mit Frankreich
zusammen zu arbeiten
allerdings spricht er auch wieder von
den legitimen Sicherheitsinteressen
aller Russland inklusive von dort kommt
direkt einer Absage China verfüge zwar
über ein herausragendes
vermittlungspotenzial doch die Situation
in der Ukraine sei komplex es gebe keine
Aussicht auf eine politische Lösung
ja wir sprechen gleich ausführlich über
das was hinter all diesen diplomatischen
Floskeln steckt erst ein weiteres
polit-treffen das Schlagzeilen macht in
Moskau empfängt Wladimir Putin seinen
belarussischen Partner Alexander
Lukaschenko die beiden Machthaber in
Minsk und Moskau sprechen ja schon seit
längerem von neuen taktischen
Atomraketen die direkt an der Grenze zu
Polen stationiert werden sollen
Lukaschenko schließt jetzt auch nicht
aus dass er strategische Nuklearwaffen
aus Russland bekommt die haben eine
größere Reichweite und noch viel mehr
Zerstörungskraft Sebastian eben
beobachtet diese atom-allianz für uns
die goldenen Flügeltüren in Kreml öffnen
sich heute erneut um zwei Autokraten
eine Bühne zu bieten die der Welt zeigen
wollen die Musik spielt nicht in Peking
sondern in Moskau doch die pompöse
aufmachen kann nicht darüber hinweg
täuschen das Putin und Lukaschenko dem
Treffen in China wenig entgegenzusetzen
haben der russische Präsidentin
gewohnter Dore Torik
das Dokumente über das wir heute
sprechen beinhaltet fundamentale Punkte
unserer Kooperation in Mitten wachsender
Spannungen außerhalb unserer Grenzen und
den Mitten von Sanktionen und einem
Informationskrieg der gegen uns geführt
wird
Putin und Lukaschenko schließen die rein
das ist die Botschaft die von diesem
zweitägigen Treffen ausgehen soll schon
gestern gab sich Putin herzlich obwohl
er seine Gäste sonst lieber an großen
Tischen und mit großen Abstand begrüßt
bis tief in die Nacht sollen die beiden
zusammen gesessen haben dabei könnte es
auch um die von Putin angekündigte
Stationierung russischer Kernwaffen in
Belarus gegangen sein doch konkret
wurden die beiden noch heute nicht
wenn nötig werden wir alles benutzen was
wir haben um unsere Länder und Bürger zu
schützen ich denke der Westen würde das
gleiche machen
700 km entfernt in der Villa russischen
Hauptstadt Minsk blickte
regimekritikerin Wolga mit Entsetzen auf
die Allianz der beiden Machthaber sie
will keine russischen Atomraketen wir
laros müsse sich nicht schützen vor dem
Westen das Land sei Teil von Europa und
Putin und Luca schenko Agressoren
ich kann mir nicht helfen aber es widert
mich an diese beiden Kreaturen zusammen
zu sehen
[Musik]
ich fühle mich so weil sie mein Land
davon abgehalten haben sich normal in
Richtung Europa zu entwickeln und ein
Teil davon zu werden
doch Lukaschenko hat andere Pläne vor
einer Woche sprach er davon dass man in
bielerus auch strategische Atomwaffen
stationieren könne Waffen von viel
zerstörerischerer Kraft Lukaschenko
würde sich nur zu gerne als Herrscher
einer nuklear macht sehen doch so viel
Macht will Putin dem Juniorpartner nicht
zugestehen
putin hatte in seiner Erklärung über die
Stationierung von Kernwaffen in Belarus
nicht erwähnt das ist ein Prinzip der
zwei Knöpfe geben oder das Lukaschenko
irgendeine Form der Kontrolle haben wird
im Gegenteil putin hatte sogar
unterstrichen dass Russland villarus
diese Waffen nicht übergeben wird
und so ist das auf Augenhöhe inszenierte
treffen heute vor allem eins ein
Schauspiel denn wir los und Lukaschenko
sind für Putin nichts weiter als
hilfreiche Statisten in seinem
geopolitischen Machtspiel
gibt's viel zu besprechen bringen wir
unsere Korrespondenten mit dazu um
herauszufinden was ich dahinter den
Kulissen tut und gucken nach Peking
Moskau und nach Brüssel Miriam Staller
guten Abend oder viel mehr guten Morgen
es gibt eine ganze Reihe von
Eilmeldungen heute über das was
Präsident hier bei dir im Peking gesagt
hat unter anderem wir wollen Frieden und
Dialog fördern jetzt haben wir aber
andererseits ja gesehen dass er gerade
sich erst deutlich an die Seite von
Wladimir Putin gestellt hat sagt er
einfach jedem Besucher in Peking was der
gerade hören will
ein bisschen ist das anscheinend so
zumindest verfolgt hier sowohl mit
Russland als auch mit Europa das gleiche
Ziel und das ist ein Gegengewicht zu den
USA aufzubauen China ist unterwegs auf
dem sehr schmalen Grad zwischen Russland
und Europa und versucht mit beiden
Seiten sich gut zu stellen und es sich
mit keiner zu sehr zu verscherzen davon
profitiert China vor allem
wirtschaftlich
und was ist konkret dann tatsächlich von
Peking zu erwarten also zum Beispiel ein
Telefonat wenigstens auch mit dem
Ukrainer selenski
das hat hier heute angekündigt dass ein
Telefonat mit dem ukrainischen
Präsidenten möglich wäre wenn Zeit und
Bedingungen passend sein das ist
natürlich maximal vage und lässt ihm
allen Spielraum das hi Druck ausübt auf
Moskau dafür gibt es keine Anzeichen bei
den Waffenlieferungen an Russland da
wird er wohl sehr viel vorsichtiger sein
denn dass der Preis dafür extrem hoch
sein würde das haben die Europäer in
Peking ihm heute noch mal sehr klar
gesagt dann gehen wir doch gleich weiter
nach Moskau zu Christian Sam kann man
davon ausgehen dass wenn China
tatsächlich Druck machen sollte das
Putin dass da nicht einfach so
ignorieren kann wie kommen denn die
Zeichen aus Peking von hier und seinen
Besuchern in Moskau an
Kreml der hat das heute erstmal
abgelehnt hat China war auf der anderen
Seite gelobt und geschmeichelt sind ja
die zwei besten neuen Freunde das haben
wir gesehen vor zwei Wochen hier in
Moskau China gelobt und gesagt das Land
sei sicherlich ein exzellenter Vertreter
für so eine Friedenslösung aber und dann
kommt das russische aber die Lage in der
Ukraine sei einfach sehr kompliziert und
hier sei nicht bereit für eine Lösung
deshalb müsste diese spezialoperation
sowie der Kriege genannt wird deswegen
müsste die weitergehen und dann haben
wir ja gerade den belarussischen
Machthaber gesehen der enorm Öl ins
Feuer gießt immer wieder die
atomwaffenkarte zumindest ja anspricht
wie viel Säbelrasseln ist denn da dabei
und wie viele tatsächlich
besorgniserregende Aufrüstung
ich würde sagen das ist beides ist aber
zunächst steht einmal vielleicht die
Drogen im Vordergrund denn bis das alles
implementiert ist so wie das geplant
sein soll wird das ja noch dauern aber
Putin weiß eben ganz genau dass er diese
Atom Drogen diese atomkarte immer wieder
spielen kann das ist ja sozusagen sein
letzter Joker und den wird er nicht aus
der Hand geben den wird er auch nicht
mit einem Alexander lukaschenkoen Teilen
Lukaschenko ist ihm untergeben und Putin
kann Belarus für seine Zwecke nutzen
dann gucken wir auf die europäische
Komponente das ganze mit unserer Mann in
Brüssel Ulf guten Abend hat Ursula von
der Leyen heute in Peking ihre neue
härtere China Politik durchgehalten
ich fand das eigentlich ganz interessant
sie hat quasi zwei Gesichter in Peking
gezeigt einmal das offizielle als sie
mit Ski vor laufenden Kameras redete da
war sie höflich sprach zwar von
komplexen Beziehungen aber vermiet
irgendwelche direkte Kritik und dann
hinter verschlossenen Türen da ist die
kommissionspräsidentin wohl sehr
deutlich geworden hat die rote Linie
zugezogen hat gesagt wenn China Waffen
an Russland liefert dann würde das
nachhaltig die Handels die Beziehung mit
Europa beschädigen und sie hat auch
gesagt es muss ein faireren Handel geben
zwischen Europa und China und falls
China das nicht macht drohte sie mit
Maßnahmen und wie sehr ist am Ende dann
doch wieder alles geprägt von der
Tatsache dass die EU rein wirtschaftlich
eben ohne China nicht klar kommt
zumindest aktuell nicht
das war auch ganz interessant die Rolle
zu sehen die Ursula von der Leyen
gespielt hat das war die europäische
etwas kräftig kräftiger und etwas
kritischer und dann war da macron und er
war doch etwas leiser und höflicher zu
Ski da hat man gemerkt ihm geht es vor
allem bei dieser Reise um nationale
Interessen eben um Wirtschaftsinteressen
und das ist wahrscheinlich das Problem
wenn es zum Schwur kommt zwischen Europa
und China werden viele nationale Länder
dann doch sagen wir brauchen die
Wirtschaft von China interessanter
Analyse herzlichen Dank nach Peking nach
Moskau und nach Brüssel und wir bleiben
noch einen Moment in Moskau wo sich auch
das Schicksal eines Kollegen von uns
allen hier entscheidet der
Zeitungsreporter Evan goskowitz ist in
Jekaterinburg im oral vom russischen
Geheimdienst festgenommen worden den
Vorwurf der Spionage weisen sowohl seine
Zeitung das Wall Street Journal als auch
die US-Regierung strikt zurück
der Fall schockiert und wirft für alle
Medien schwierige Fragen auf wie viel
juristischen Schutz genießen offizieller
kreditierte Auslandskorrespondenten noch
in Russland mit wie viel Willkür haben
sie zu rechnen und was ist zu tun damit
Evan gerettet frei kommt Andrea Maurer
ist dem nachgegangen
seit einer Woche ist der us-reporter
Evan goschkovich im berüchtigten
Gefängnis lefo in Moskau inhaftiert
für seinen Freund und Kollegen Anton
trojanowski der das Moskauer Büro der
New York Times aktuell von Berlin
ausleitet ist diese Verhaftung ein neuer
Tabubruch durch Putin in der Zeit nach
dem Kalten Krieg es hat nie einen Fall
gegeben in Russland das ein
ausländischer Journalist als angeblicher
Spion festgenommen war wir wissen dass
er wenn faktisch jetzt ein Geisel des
russischen Staates ist
31 Sohn jüdisch-russischer Immigranten
war 2017 ins Land seiner Eltern
zurückgekehrt um zu berichten seit 2022
als Reporter für das Wort Street Germany
der russische Geheimdienst hat ihnen
vergangenen Mittwoch verhaftet wirft ihm
vor im Zitat Interesse der
amerikanischen Regierung Informationen
gesammelt zu haben
Spionage verhaftet
US-Außenminister blinken hat jetzt mit
unserem Außenminister lavrov telefoniert
aber über diesen Fall entscheiden nicht
lavrov und blinken sondern die Beweise
die die laufenden Untersuchungen dem
Gericht liefern
es gibt keine unabhängige Justiz in
Russland Russland ist eine Diktatur und
deswegen müssen wir mit dem Schlimmsten
rechnen und unsere Forderung anders
russische Regime muss sein Herrn
gerschkovic unverzüglich freizulassen
und das bedingungslos
spionageverfahren in Russland aber sind
langwierig und Bedingungen wird die
russische Führung mit hoher
Wahrscheinlichkeit stellen sagt auch der
ehemalige deutsche Botschafter in Moskau
Rüdiger von Fritsch sie greift hier zu
einem besonders harten Mittel sie will
einen Preis hochtreiben der ganz
offensichtlich steht zu vermuten dass
die russische Führung mit der Verhaftung
von darauf zielt eine freipressung zu
erreichen möglicherweise so Rüdiger von
Fritsch könnte der Kreml auch Interesse
an einem russischen Gefangenen in
Deutschland haben war dem grasiko nicht
auszuschließen ist das erneut wie schon
in der Vergangenheit die Freilassung
gefordert wird jenes kaltblütigen
Mörders der im Auftrag des russischen
Geheimdienstes wie nachgewiesen werden
konnte 2019 in Berliner Tiergarten ein
titanischen
Oppositionellen ermordete das sind die
Art Preise die die russische Führung
verlangt noch im Juli twittert
avengerich über Russland zu berichten
heißt jetzt regelmäßig Menschen die man
kennt für Jahre ins Gefängnis wandern zu
sehen nun hat es George selbst getroffen
sein Fall ändert viel fast alle
us-korrespondenten haben das Land
verlassen anton trojanowski hat Erwin
einen Brief ins Gefängnis geschickt ich
habe ihm geschrieben dass ich weiß dass
er stark ist ein sehr starker Mensch ist
und dass er dass er hier durchkommt am
18 April wird Erwin dem Haftrichter
vorgeführt ihm drohen bis zu 20 Jahre
Gefängnis
nicht nur die großen US-Medien auch die
Spitzen der wichtigsten Zeitungen und
Sender in Frankreich fordern in einem
Protestbrief an den russischen
Botschafter die sofortige Freilassung
des Kollegen seine Verhaftung so heißt
es dort sei eine Warnung eine Drohung an
die letzten Vertreter der
internationalen Presse die sich noch in
Russland aufhalten um nicht zu sagen ein
Akt des Terrors
Gundula jetzt hier bei uns mit einem
ersten Nachrichten Überblick
China wirft den USA und Taiwan
ungeheuerliches Fehlverhalten vor der
Anlass ein Besuch von Taiwans
Präsidentin sei im US-Bundesstaat
Kalifornien Peking kündigte
entschlossene Maßnahmen an und hat
Kriegsschiffe in die Gewässer um Taiwan
geschickt
sei dankte dem Vorsitzenden des
US-Repräsentantenhauses für die
Unterstützung der USA für Taiwan das
Rang hohe treffen verschärft die
Spannungen zwischen den USA und China
das Taiwan als abtrünnige Provinz
betrachtet
in Frankreich sind am mittlerweile 11
Protesttage wieder zehntausende gegen
die Rentenreform von Präsident macron
auf die Straße gegangen trotz eines
großaufgebots der Polizei kam es erneut
zur Ausschreitungen unter anderem in
Paris Lyon und Mond setzte die Polizei
Tränengas gegen die Demonstranten ein
sie protestierten gegen die schrittweise
Anhebung des Renteneintrittsalters von
62 auf 64 Jahre und die Gewerkschaften
hatten gestern ein schlichtungstreffen
mit der Regierung abgebrochen
mehr Mittel im Kampf gegen
Cyber-Attacken das fordern Politiker
mehrere Parteien nach den
Hackerangriffen auf Internetseiten von
Bund und Ländern seit Tagen legen
Kriminelle mit
überlastungsangriffen die
Internetauftritte verschiedener Behörden
vorübergehend lernen zu einigen davon
hat sich eine pro russische Gruppe im
Nachrichtendienst Telegramm bekannt
betroffen sind zum Beispiel
Polizeibehörden in Niedersachsen die
Landeskriminalämter ermitteln
die Auswirkungen der fortschreitenden
Erderwärmung registriert die EU seit 25
Jahren mit ihrem Umwelt
Beobachtungsprogramm Kopernikus nach
dessen Daten war der März der
zweitwärmste seit Beginn der
Aufzeichnungen und das mehr Eis in der
Antarktis hat sich im März deutlich
weniger ausgedehnt als üblich mit 28%
unter dem Durchschnitt der zweit
niedrigste Stand für einen März seit
in Jerusalem kommt alles zusammen immer
schon genau genommen nicht mal in
Jerusalem generell sondern auf ein paar
hundert Metern im Zentrum der alten
Stadt die gleich drei Weltreligionen
heilig ist aktuell gilt das nicht nur
historisch religiös auch der Kalender
trägt dazu bei dass jüdische Pessachfest
läuft die Muslime beginnen den
Fastenmonat Ramadan und für die Christen
beginnen die Ostertage dazu kommt die
politische Gesamtlage und speziell die
Verfassungskrise in Israel es gibt
heftige Zusammenstöße auf dem Tempelberg
und in der Alexa Moschee es gibt Raketen
auf Israel auch im Norden aus dem
Libanon und in Jerusalem wo sich aber
tausende Gläubige versammelt haben
halten Sie den Atem an Michael warum
36 Raketen aus dem Libanon auf Israel
das hat es lange nicht gegeben zum Glück
nur drei Verletzte ansonsten vor allem
Sachschaden doch der Schock ist groß die
Situation im Land ist ohnehin angespannt
genug
es gab Alarm und darauf einen Knall in
der Luft das Auto das gerade an meinem
Haus vorbei fuhr bekam Trümmerteile der
Rakete ab schon vorher ist der Konflikt
um die alle AXA Moschee und den
Tempelberg eskaliert barrikadierte
Palästinenser schießen Feuerwerkskörper
auf Polizisten die reagieren mit
schlagstätten und Festnahme das alles zu
einem Zeitpunkt den das Land durch einen
verfassungsstreit innenpolitisch
zerrissen wird
[Applaus]
die Familie feiern die Israelis gerade
das besser fest im ganzen Land sitzen
dann Familien um den gedeckten Tisch und
singen aus der hagada der biblischen
Geschichte vom Auszug der Israeliten aus
Ägypten
für die Familie von Israel schafi hat
dieses Pessach eine besondere Bedeutung
Religion alle der kotname des expiloten
der viele Schlachten für sein Land
geschlagen hat
wir können zwei Dinge von Pessach lernen
zum einen befreie Dich und versklave
andere nicht
für diese Überzeugung gehen er und seine
Familie seit Monaten auf die Straße
gegen die sogenannte Justizreform
an die eine Million Leute kommen und
sagen unsere Freiheit hängt von einer
freien und starken Justiz ab und von
gewaltenteilunges
der Streit spaltet die Nation und hat
schon manche Freundschaft gekostet
es ist schwer zu verstehen und schwer zu
erklären bei Menschen mit dieser
strikten Gesinnung der anderen Seite und
ich habe das Gefühl dass ich nicht mehr
mit ihnen zusammen sein kann zumindest
jetzt
demonstriert dagegen dass Urteile des
Obersten Gerichtshofs mit der Mehrheit
der Knesset Abgeordneten überstimmt
werden dürfen genau das aber wie die
andere Seite durchsetzen und mobilisiert
dafür ihren Protest auch sie glauben den
Staat Israel retten zu müssen und sehen
nicht dass die Demokratie auch
demokratisch abgeschafft werden kann
das Oberste Gericht erlaubt sich mehr
als es sollte es mischt sich in Sachen
ein in die sich nicht einmischen sollte
obwohl es nicht demokratisch gewählt
wurde das ist Diktatur wir unterstützen
die Reform die die Macht in die Hände
der gewählten Politiker geben wird
zum Streiten die Justizreform kommt nun
die Eskalation der Gewalt vor dem
Karfreitag an dem zehntausende
christliche muslimische Pilger in
Jerusalem erwartet werden
das ist so nicht weitergehen kann
diskutieren Sie auch an Pessach Tisch
von Familie scharfier die Fragen sind
wie sehr versklaven wir die
Palästinenser wie sehr ist das ihre
Schuld und was können wir tun um die
Situation zu verbessern
doch der Riss durch Israels Gesellschaft
ist in dieser Frage wohl tiefer als
alles andere
[Musik]
zur aktuellen Situation kommen im Nahen
Osten Michael wie ist denn diese
Gemengelage diese brisante Gemengelage
in den Griff zu bekommen gerade auch mit
der Eskalation an der libanesischen
Grenze im Norden
das ist schwer zu rauf vorauszusagen
Premiere tanjao ist gerade vor die
Presse getreten und hat ganz allgemein
nur eine Antwort angekündigt er sagte
unsere Feinde sollten sich nicht
täuschen die interne Diskussion Israel
wird werden das Land nicht hindern gegen
seine Feinde vorzugehen an jedem Ort zu
jeder Zeit wenn notwendig damit räumt er
offen ein dass Israel zumindest
geschwächt wird nach außen mit einem
Verteidigungsminister der eigentlich nur
noch kommissarisch im Amt wird weil er
sich im verfassungsstreit um die
Justizreform offen gegen jau gestellt
hat diese Schwäche versucht nun offenbar
die haben Maß auszunutzen indem sie den
Konflikt weiter auch aus dem Libanon
eskalieren wird auch zur Frage wie
geht's denn nun morgen am Karfreitag in
Jerusalem weiter wo eben zehntausende
Pilger zusammenkommen hatte nur gesagt
es gebe keine Änderung des Status quo
auf dem Tempelberg aber Israel werde mit
harter Hand gegen diejenigen Vorgehen
die dort Gewalt ausüben wollten also
auch hier ist nicht klar an der Linie
wie sich die Linie ändern wird eher
nicht und für morgen ist eine weitere
Eskalation daher eher zu befürchten
Michael Beverungen ZDF Teller wie vielen
Dank
und hier bei uns noch mal duodola mit
einer guten Nachricht aus der deutschen
Wirtschaft dank steigender Aufträge
fahren die Unternehmen ihre Produktion
weiter hoch das Plus überrascht denn
Inflation und Energiekrise ließen ein
Minus erwarten Sie mir meinen jetzt an
der Börse wie erklärt sich diese Wende
ja diese Wende erklärt sich erstens
durch steigende Nachfrage und zweitens
durch eine deutliche Entspannung bei den
Lieferketten so dass bereits bestehende
Aufträge jetzt endlich abgearbeitet
werden können ein Volkswirt bezeichnete
bereits den Januar als Sahne Monat für
die deutsche Industrie der Februar hat
ihn sogar noch getoppt ein Fluss von 2%
gegenüber dem Vormonat dank florierender
exporter und mehr Industrie Aufträgen es
sieht so aus als hätte die deutsche
Wirtschaft die Talsohle durchschritten
und die Rezession vorerst abgewendet
auch das Bruttoinlandsprodukt steigt
wieder leicht an ebenso er ging es dem
DAX in der Karwoche er geht mit einem
Plus von einem halben Prozent ins lange
Osterwochenende am Ende entstand von 15
1.598 Punkten ja mit solch einer
schnellen Erholung der deutschen
Industrie hatten wohl die wenigsten
gerechnet und in welchem Branchen läuft
es denn besonders gut ein besonders
großen Anteil an diesem Plus in der
Gesamtproduktion hatte das Zug fährt der
deutschen Wirtschaft die
Automobilindustrie ein Zuwachs von 7,6
Prozent im Februar verglichen zum Januar
auch ein Plus bei der Chemie und
Metallindustrie von 1,9% und in der
Bauindustrie noch ein Zugewinn von
1,5%. wichtigster Handelspartner
Deutschlands bleiben die USA ob sich
dieser positive Trend also fortsetzt
hängt auch davon ab wie sich die dortige
Wirtschaft entwickelt weiterhin
steigende Zinsen bremsen die Konjunktur
aus und auch die Themen Energie und
geopolitische Spannungen könnten
dämpfend auf die florierende Wirtschaft
wirken vielen Dank Sina nach Frankfurt
Gründonnerstag ist traditionell ein Stau
trächtiger Tag und nach der Pandemie
nutzen wieder mehr Menschen die
Osterfeiertage für eine Kurzreise auf
der A7 südlich von Hamburg stauten sich
die Autos auf 35 km zusätzlich zum
Osterreiseverkehr waren die Auto und
Lkw-Fahrer dort von klimaaktivisten
blockiert worden die sich erneut in
Hamburg dort am Eingang zum Elbtunnel
festgeklebt hatten bis die Straßen
wieder frei waren dauerte es Stunden
in Rom haben die Osterfeierlichkeiten
begonnen und Papst franziskus nimmt nach
seinem Krankenhausaufenthalt an allen
Teil als ein Zeichen der Demut wusch der
86-Jährige in einem Jugendgefängnis
Häftlingen die Füße eine biblisch
überlieferte Geste von Jesus beim
letzten Abendmahl zuvor hatte der Papst
die gründonnerstagsmesse in Petersdom
gefeiert und morgen will franziskus an
der kreuzwegsprozession teilnehmen
so und damit sagen wir danke für heute
und freuen uns an Karsamstag wieder auf
sie 0.15 ist hier noch mal Zeit für
unser heute journal Update mit Nazan
göttinieren vom gesamten Team auch den
Kolleginnen und Kollegen hinter den
Kameras ein angenehmen Abend auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen Abend und herzlich willkommen
zum Wetter der Blick zurück auf den März
global und das sind die Kopernikus Daten
und wir sehen es war teilweise viel zu
kalt zum Beispiel über Nordamerika hier
gab es immer wieder kaltluftausbrüche
aus der Arktis ähnlich war es auch in
Nordeuropa aber teilweise auch viel zu
warm Richtung Asien und der märz fällt
auf den zweiten Platz global betrachtet
und in Europa ja das sehen wir auch noch
mal genauer hier über Spanien
Mitteleuropa bis nach Russland deutlich
zu warm und zu kalt Richtung
Skandinavien und sogar mal Richtung
Spitzbergen ebenfalls zu kalt der Blick
auf Europa und damit mit Regen zu tun
der ist schon reingezogen verlagert sich
in den Süden weiterer Regen kommt von
Osten her auf und der bleibt
hauptsächlich dann auch in den östlichen
Landesteilen und das in der Nacht vor
allem im Westen dann mit Regen und auch
im Süden nach Osten hin klartis auf in
die Temperaturen gehen zurück auf 0 bis
-3 Grad ganz im Westen sieben Grad plus
deutlich milder und morgen also im
Südwesten Regen teilweise Schauer und
Gewitter und im Osten kommt eben dieser
Regen aus Polen herauf und dazwischen
gibt's viel Sonnenschein weil höchsten
Temperaturen von 13 bis 14 Grad im
Nordwesten deutlich kälter an der oder-
und Neiße sechs bis sieben Grad und
Karsamstag vor allem im Osten
durchwachsen mit vielen Wolken und Regen
sonst trocken 7 bis 14 Grad und ab
Ostern Sonntag wird's allmählich wärmer
und vor allem Ostermontag dann bis 18
Grad ein schöner Abend